[موسيقى]
الحصاد معكم عبد القادر عياد الوقت الذي
يحدث فيه تقع واحداث وتتفاعل اخرى في
مناطق مختلفه من العالم البدايه من رام
الله بعد ساعات من تصديق وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي بينيجانس على اقامه الجدار
الاسمنتي بطول 100 كيلو متر شمال الضفه
الغربيه المحتله لاستبدال السياجي القديم
ثم الى طهران حيث اعلن الحرس الثوري
الايراني في وقت سابقا اليوم تنفيذ عمليه
عسكريه باستخدام الصواريخ والمسيرات في
اقليم كردستان العراق ثم الى لندن هذه
المره والاعلان عن اتفاق جديد بين
بريطانيا وفرنسا للحد من عبور طالب اللجوء
بحر المانش وهي قضيه العلاقات بين البلدين
الى حدين كبير
وفي مواضع الحصاد هذه الليله
[موسيقى]
على وقع قطيعه سياسيه وعقوبات وتصعيد
كلامي صحته اوكرانيا مباحثات روسيه
امريكيه متتابعه في انقره بينها لقاء بين
مديرياتها واشنط تقول انها ستبحث منع اي
تصعيد النووي
ووصف تقارير عن ضغوط الامريكيه
للعوده للتفاوض مع روسيا هيربي يؤكد
للجزيره ان الرئيس الاوكراني وحده من يحدد
التوقيت
في اول قمه مباشره بين الرئيسين الامريكي
والصيني بعد اسابيع من التصعيد
الى صراع ويثير مع نظيره الصيني المخاوف
من سلوك كوريا
الشماليهوان ستبقى الخط الاحمر الاول
[موسيقى]
بعد يومين على تفجير اسطنبول وزير
الداخليه التركي يقول ان الدلائل تشير الى
مسؤوليه حزب العمال الكردستاني
بعد تلقيها تدريبات من حزب العمال
الكردستاني ووحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
والامن يعتقل 46 شخصا اخرين ويقول انهبط
هجمات الاخرى محتمله
بعد قصف الايراني على اقليم كردستان شمالي
العراق ادى الى مقتل شخصين واصابه ثمانيه
اخرين بغداد تلوي حب الرد باجراءات
دبلوماسيه وترفض انتهاك سيادتها وتمديد
الامريكيون وامومي
جاءت بعد فشل جهود اخراج من وصفتها
بالجماعات الارهابيه من الاقليم
النبي
نحن اليوم
الواحد لازم انه نحن بحاجه للرئيس جمهوريه
على واقع ازمه الاستحقاق الرئاسي في لبنان
نجيب ميقاتي يقول للجزيره ان الرئيس يجب
ان لا يشكل تحديا لاي طرف ويكشف عن دعمه
الفرنجيه رئيسا للبلاد ويكشف اتصالات مع
واشنطن لتفادي عقوبات امريكيه اذا قابلت
بيروت هبه النفطيه الايراني
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقم يكن لقد ناقشنا معكم سياقه اللقاء
الذي جمع مدير وكاله المخابرات المركزيه
الامريكيه وليامرز ونظيره الروسيه في
انقره بمبادره من واشنطن وفقا لمقاله
الكربلا استطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع
كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم
في اي صيام ياتي لقاء مديريه الاستخبارات
الامريكي والروسي نحو 66% قالوا انها
تسويه محتمله في اوكرانيا ونحو واحد
وعشرين في المئه قالوا انه بحث قضايا
ثنائيه خلافيه بينما صوت نحو 13 بالمئه
بالقول انها رسائل من واشنطن لموسكو
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا في منصتنا الرقميه
يمكنكم دخول من اصل الصفحه التصويت عبر
مزح مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقاؤنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
تطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه قرار الاسرائيلي
ببناء 100 كم جديد من جدار الفصل العنصري
[موسيقى]
هكذا رئيس دائره الاتصال التابعه للرئاسه
التركيه فخر الدين في تصريحه وكاله
ان اللقاء بين رئيسين الاستخبارات الروسيه
والامريكيه جرى باستضافه جهاز الاستخبارات
التركيه واعتبر اللقاء مساهمه جديده تضاف
الى المساهمات المهمه التي قدمها الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان الى السلام
العالمي على حد تعبيره واكد رئيس دائره
الاتصال التابعه للرئاسه التركيه ان
اللقاء بحثت تهديدات التي يواجهها الامن
الدولي وعلى راسها استعمال الاسلحه
النوويه وشدد على ان تركيا ستستمر في
التفاوض مع جميع الاطراف لاحلال السلام
وانها لم تتردد في القيام
بالمبادره خلال ذلك
مره اخرى وبعيدا عن الاضواء تنجح
الاولويات الامنيه والاستراتيجيه في
اختراق جدار القطيعه الامريكي الروسي الذي
فاقمته الحرب على اوكرانيا
العاصمتان واشنطن و موسكو اكدتا ان لقاء
يجمع في انقره مديره وكاله المخابرات
المركزيه الامريكيه سيايه ويليامبرز مع
رئيس جهاز المخابرات الخارجيه الروسيه
سيرجينار شكين وكاي اجتماع امني يتحفظ
الجانبان عن التفاصيل لكن ما تسرب على
الامريكيين يشير الى ان بيرز ذهب الى
تركيا لا من اجل التفاوض لتسويه الحرب في
اوكرانيا بل لتحذير الروس من عواقب
استخدام اسلحه النوويه وخطر التصعيد على
الاستقرار الاستراتيجي اما الكريم فاعلن
ان محادثات انقره تعقد بمبادره من
الولايات المتحده وانها تجري بضيافه جهاز
الاستخبارات التركي
تكن الحيثيات فالواضح ان قنوات التواصل
السريه بين موسكو وواشنطن باتت حقيقه
تتخطى حاله التدهور المعلن في العلاقات
الثنائيه منذ الهجوم الروسيه على اوكرانيا
ف قبل ايام كشف مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جيكسوليفان عن انخراطه في
محادثات سريه مع مسؤولينا روس كبار
للحيلوله دون تصعيد النووي لكن جهود اداره
المخاطر تلك لا تبدو منفصله عن جهود
امريكيه حفيفه لايجاد تسويه للحرب في
اوكرانيا وهي رغبه تتنام هذه الايام في
اروقه صنع القرار في واشنطن صحيفه ولستريد
جورنال الامريكيه نقلت عن مصادر مطلعه ان
سلفان ابلغ الرئيس الاوكراني خلال لقائه
في كيف بضروره الانفتاح على المفاوضات لان
كيف ستكتسب نفوزا من خلال اظهار تحيا على
التفاوض
وذكرت الصحيفه ان مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي اوصى زنسكي وفريقه بالبدئ في
التفكير في مطالب واقعيه وباولويات
التفاوض بما في ذلك اعاده النظر في الهدف
المعلن المتمثل باستعاده اوكرانيا شبه
جزيره القرم حتى الان تتمسك كيف بموقفها
وتشترط استعاده كل الاراضي قبل اي حوار مع
موسكو لكن تطورات الاوضاع وتبدل المعطيات
بما فيها ربما تزايد ضغطي واشنطن ومزيد من
التقارب الامريكي الروسي قد يقنع
الاوكرانيين باعاده ترتيب اولوياتهم لا
سيما بعد المكاسب الميدانيه التي يحققها
هجومهم المضاد في شرق البلاد وجنوبها
هذا وكان منسق للاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون كربي قال
للجزيره ان الولايات المتحده ستواصل دعم
القوه الاخرانيه ميدانيا واكد ان الرئيسكي
وحده من يختاروا توقيت التفاوضى مع روسيا
يمكن ان يعرف متى ستنتهي ما يمكن التحدث
به على وجه اليقين هو اننا سنستمر في دعم
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في الميدان حتى
تتمكن من الاستمرار في تحقيق المزيد من
النجاح
الرئيسكي وحده من يحدد متى يكون مستعدا
لجلوس والتفاوض مع الروس بشروطه وبطريقه
التي يختارها
ينضم الينا من لندن كبير محلليه شؤون
روسيا واراسيا في معهد شتم هاوس اهلا بك
سيد جايلس باعتقادك ما السبب الرئيسي او
مضمون هذا اللقاء الاول بين رئيس
الاستخبارات في البلدين منذ انطلاق الحرب
في اوكرانيا
حول الاسلحه النوويه وتستجابه للتهديدات
التي اطلقها الرئيس
ان هذا هو الموضوع الوحيد ولكن كده
الطرفين سلطاته على اهميته لماذا الاهلي
ان كان هذا هو الملف ال- ال- الاكثر
ترجيحا في ما يتعلق باستعماله الاسلحه
النوويه
هذا صحيح اذا
الحيه بتحدث عن موضوع الاسلحه النوويه قد
يظن البعض انها قد مرت لان هذه التهديدات
لم تؤخذ على محمل الجد وتم تجاهل هذه
التهديدات ولكن في الحقيقه تبرز الحاجه
لكل الطرفين قال الولايات المتحده وروسيا
لتامين الاستقرار الاستراتيجي اي التحدث
بكل ما يحصل بخصوص النزاع في اوكرانيا
وليست بالضروره ان يكون مرتبطا بشكل مباشر
بهذا النزاع من غير المرجح ان يكون هناك
رسائل حول الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حول
موقف اوكرانيا من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولكن يجب ان لا نثني امكانيه
تمرير الرسائل عبر الولايات المتحده من
كيف الى روسيا ماذا عم يتم تسريبه او
اعلان هو من قبل وسائل الاعلام عن ضغوط
امريكيه على كليب من اجل التوجه للتفاوض
تم تسليط الضوء عليه بشكل مستمر في خلال
هذا النزاع ولا يفاجئنا هناك
اعتقاد بان التوصل الى حل التفوضي هو
الطريق الوحيده لوضعي حدد لهذه الحرب ولكن
هذه الدعوات خفت بالبقره مع مكان عليه
الوضع في خلال فصل الصيف كان هناك مخاوف
بان اوكرانيا سوف تخسر هذه الحرب وان
الحرب سوف تستمر الى ما لا نهايه هذه
المخاوف تبددت لان اوكرانيا اثبتت ان
باستطاعتها ان تضغط على القوات الروسيه
وتؤدي الى انسحاب القوات الروسيه وهذا غير
اطار الحوار ولكن في خلفيت هذا الحوار
هناك اقرار بانه في مرحله معينه يتعين على
روسيا واوكرانيا
في معهد شتم هاوس شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الامريكي الولايات المتحده
عادت لقياده العالم وستحافظ على
التزاماتها تصريحات بعيد جاءت عشيه انطلاق
قمه مجموعه العشرين وبعد اول لقاء قمه
مباشر يجمعه برئيس الصيني
ان الطرفين
لاداره التنافس بينهما
الجيش
واجرينا حديثا حول نوايانا واولوياتنا
واتفقنا على الدفاع عن المصالح والقيم
الامريكيه وتعزيز قيم الانسان والوقوف الى
جانب النظام العالمي سوف نتنافس بشده وسوف
ندير التنافس بمسؤوليه وندعوا الدول
للالتزام بالقواعد العالميه كما نقشنا
سياسه الصين الواحده وانها لم تتغير اتفقت
معك على الحفاظ على الامن والاستقرار في
مضيق تايوان وسنعمل سويا على التصدي
للتحديات العالميه
هذا وقال البيت الابيض انه بيدن ابلغ
نظيره وصيني يشير جيم بنك ان التنفس بين
البلدين يجب الا يتحول ابدا الى صراع
واضاف البيت الابيض ان بيد ابلغ شيء
بضروره اداره واشنطن المنافسه بينهما
والحفاظ على قنوات الاتصال واشار البيت
الابيض الى ان بيض وشينا بشكل صريح
اولويات البلدين وعددا من القضايا وبشان
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قال البيت الابيض
ان بيض وشير اتفق على معارضه استخدام
الاسلحه النوويه في اوكرانيا
على جانب الاخر افادت وسائل اعلام صينيه
ان الرئيس سيرجي بينج شدد على ان تايوان
ستبقى الخط الاحمر الاول في العلاقات
بينها وبين واشنطن ووضحا ان اي جهه تسعى
لفصل عن الصين تنتهي كل المصالح الاساسيه
لامتهم وقال الرئيس الصيني انه يامل ان
يقرنا الجانب الامريكي اقواله بالافعال
وان يلتزم بسياسه الصين الواحده وفقا لما
جاء في وسائل اعلام صينيه
وقال الرئيس الصيني اذا انه يريد محادثات
صريحه مع بيدن بشان القضايا الاستراتيجيه
في العلاقات الصينيه الامريكيه والمسائل
الاقليميه وكذلك الدوري
50 عاما مرت منذ بدايه العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين الصين والولايات المتحده
شهيدنا خلالها احداثا كثيره واكتسبنا
التجربه والخبرات وتعلمنا الدروس التاريخ
هو افضل كتاب نتعلم منه وعلينا ان ننظر
للتاريخ كي نرسم المستقبل
كرئيسين لدولتين عظيمتين علينا رسم المسار
الصحيح للعلاقات الثنائيه وتعزيز هذه
العلاقه اي رجل دوله يجب ان يعرف كيف يقود
بلده وكيف يتوافق مع الدول الاخرى والعالم
يتوقع العالم من الصين وامريكا ان تتعامل
بطريقه مناسبه وقد حظي اجتماعنا باهتمام
العالم في اجتماعنا اليوم انا جاهز ليكون
لدينا تبادل اراء صريح في ما يخص المسائل
المهمه استراتيجيا في العلاقات الصينيه
الامريكيه والمسائل الاقليميه والعالميه
لنعيد العلاقات الى مسارها الصحيح من اجل
خدمه البلدين والعالم
هذا و تشهد العلاقات بين الولايات المتحده
والصين تنافس حادا له ابعد استراتيجيه
واقتصاديه وتؤدي هذه المنافسه الى ازمات
متتاليه تبقي علاقه البلدين في حاله توتر
شبه دائم التغير التالي يعرض بعضا من
ابعاد هذا الصراع بين اكبر قوتين
اقتصاديتين في العالم
تعتبر الولايات المتحده النظام الصيني
استبداديا وتعتقد انه الوحيد القادر على
تحدي النظام الدولي القائم اما الصين فترى
ان الولايات المتحده تريد ان تبقي هيمنتها
على النظام العالمي المستمره منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه يتجلى الصراع او
المنافسه الصينيه الامريكيه اكثر في منطقه
بحر جنوب الصين
وخارجي» تقول الولايات المتحده ان الهدف
الاول للحفاظ على وجود عسكري كبير في
المنطقه هو حمايه حلفائها خصوصا تايوان
وكوريا الجنوبيه واليابان اما الهدف
الثاني فهو ضمانه حريه الملاحه التجاريه
والاصول الى اسواق المنطقه اما السينما
تعتبر بالصين من طاقه نفوذ خالصه لها
وتعتبر تايوان جزءا من ترابها ولذلك عملت
على تطوير سلاحها البحري فانتقل عدد قطع
الى البحريه من 120 عام 2000 الى 360 عام
2020 كما اقامت جزرا صناعيه وسلحتها ودخلت
في نزاعات مع عدد من دول المنطقه بشان
السياده على مناطق بحريه واسعه ومنعتها من
التنقيب عن مصادر الطاقه فيها الى جانب
هذا الصراع الاستراتيجيه الاقليمي هناك
منافسه اقتصاديه بين الصين والولايات
المتحده باعتبارهما القوتين الاولى
والثانيه ويمثلان معا اكثر من 35 في المئه
من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي العالمي تعاني
الولايات المتحده من عجز تجاري في علاقتها
مع الصين انتقل من 83 مليار دولار عام
2001 الى 375 مليار دولار عام 2017
تشتكي واشنطن من منافسه تجاريه صينيه تقول
انها غير شريفه لكن ما يقلقها اكثر وسعي
الصين الى اكتساب التكنولوجيا المتطوره
كما يقلقها ما تعتبره رغبه في مد الصين
الى تها بعيدا خصوصا في افريقيا من خلال
مشروع طريق الحرير فالصين هي الشريك تجاري
الاول لافريقيا منذ 12 عاما وبلغت
مبادلاته تجاريه معها ما قيمته
187 مليار دولار عام 2019 وما بين 2000 و
2019 منحت الصين اكثر من الفرد لحكومات
وشركات عامه افريقيه بقيمه
153 مليار دولار
[موسيقى]
يضم الينا من ضلاوير لاري كورب مساعد وزير
الدفاع الامريكيه السابق وكبير الباحثين
في مركز التقدم الامريكي وكذلك ينضم الينا
من بيجين فيكتور جاو رئيس مركز الصين
والعولمه اهلا بضيفيه
الكريمين ابداء بك ضيفه
باعتقادك ما الذي تحقق في هذه القمه
الهامه والهامه جدا والاولى بين بيض كرئيس
والرئيس الصيني
واي فاي
اوضح كلا الطرفين المواقف التي لديهما
بخصوص تايوان على سبيل المثال الصين تشعر
بان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تشجع
تايوان على الانفصال عن الصين قال الرئيس
كلا ولكنه قال انه لا يودوا ان توحد الصين
وتتوحد مع تايوان من خلال استخدام القوه
اذا ما قامت الصين بذلك الولايات المتحده
سوف تنظر بالخطوات التاليه ايضا تحدث عن
تغير المناخ والتفاقات على انه الا في
حاله اخذنا التدابير محدده سوف نواجه
كارثه عالميه من خلال الاحترار العالمي
ارتفاع حراره الارض وازمه المناخ التي
تؤدي الى
تغيري الاحوال هنا في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وفي كل انحاء العالم
واعتقد ان النقطه الاساسيه انهما تحدث مع
بعضهما البعض وقد اوضحها ايضا ما هو الوضع
في اوكرانيا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
قالت بشكل اساسي انه يعود الامر لاوكرانيا
ان تقرر ما اذا كانت تود ان تتفاوض مع
روسيا ولكن النقطه الاساسيه هي ان الصين
ايضا همم تتفق على فكره التوصل الى حل
تفوضيه عودا عن اعطاء شكا على بياض للروس
جاوا الرئيس الصيني حارس على القول او
بالدعوه دعوه الطرف الامريكي الى ما وصفها
بحوار صريح فيما يتعلق بكل القضايا
الاستراتيجيه بين بيجين واشنطن فيما يتعلق
بالقضايا الاقليميه وكذلك الدوليه ما
المقصود بالحوار الصريح
في الصباح
الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والصين
وبرد النظر عن الاختلافات في وجهات النظر
يتعين عليه ماء ان يتعاملان مع هذه
الاختلافات من خلال سبل السلميه والحوار
عوضا عن استخدام
اعتقد ان الرئيسين تمكن من الافساح في
المجال امام العلاقات الثنائيه بين
البلدين
وعزازات امكانيه البناء على هذا اللقاء
بالنسبه الى المستقبل يتعين على البلدين
ان يستخدمه
والشجاعه لتعزيز العلاقات الثنائيه للقيام
بالامر الصائب الا وهو تحسين العلا
الثنائيه اعتقد ان الرئيس الصيني شدد
للرئيس الامريكي ان الصين ليست عدو
للولايات المتحده ولا تود ان تواجه
الولايات المتحده بل ان تكون لديها علاقه
مع الولايات المتحده ومن اجل تحقيق ذلك
واذا تحقق ذلك سوف يكون ذلك لمصلحه
الشعبين الصيني والامريكي وبالتالي اعتقد
ان الجميع في العالم يجب ان يرتاح
لرؤيه هذا القائد
واذا ما عنا بالفعل الرئيس بايدا ما قاله
الولايات المتحده لن تدخل في مواجهه مع
الصين ولن يكون هناك حرب بارده وهو امرا
اساسي ويتعين على البلد
مهمه اسال على ضيفه
ايضا الرئيس قال بانه لم يكون هناك اجتياح
من قبل الصين
هل نتكلم عن ضمانات ربما يكون الرئيس
الصيني او الرئيس الامريكي قد تلقاه من
الجانب الصيني باعتقادك
انه لا يمكن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ان تقول ان التايوان ليست جزءا من الصين
هذا امر نحله بي انفسنا لم يتحدث عن
استخدام القوه العسكريه ولكنه قال ان
الصين لا ان تايوان لا يمكنها ان تحافظ
على استقلالها الى ما لا نهايه يجب ان
يتوقف هذا الامر في مرحله معينه واعتقد ان
الرئيس قال ان هذه العمليه لا تنتهي من
خلال استعمال القوه وبالتالي كما ذكر
زميلي الدكتور
مجرد الحديث بين الرجلين هو امر جيد
وزير الخارجيه سوف يزوره الصين
وتكونوا بالتالي الزياره الاولى من هذا
النوع بعد اصول اداره فايدن الى السلطه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه باضافه الى
ذلك الرئيس شي تمت تسميته لعهده خامسه وهو
امر غير مسبوق الرئيس قبل بلاء افضل في
الانتخابات الداخليه بالمقارنه الناس
ور مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق
وكبير الباحثين في مركز تقدم الامريكي
وكذلك الشكر لضيفه من
رئيس مركز الصين
[موسيقى]
بعد مرور نحوي 24 ساعه على وقوع الانفجار
في شارع الاستقلال وسط مدينه اسطنبول
التركيه عادت الحركه العاديه الى المكان
وفتحت المحال التجاريه مجددا لكن مع بعض
من عاش التفجير مازال تحت الصدمه
[موسيقى]
لحظه وقوع الهجوم
يورينا في هذا التسجيل الذي صوره احد
زملائه من من اصيبوا وهو ملقا على الارض
قبل ان يشرع هو في مساعده فرق الان
كل شيء حدث بسرعه
ووالدها
على بعد امتار فقط
الحزن يعلو وجوه من حضروا الى مكان سقوط
القتلى
بعضهم جاء للتعبير عن تضامنه مع اهالي
الضحايا مسؤولون اتراك حضروا الى هنا
لاعلان عزم الدوله التركيه على ردع ما
وصفوه بمحاولات زعزعه الاستقرار
لكنني
تركيا تستمر
حتى وان كان اثر الهجوم وما خلفه من
ضحاياه
سيبقى محفورا في الوجدان
اقصى العقوبات بالجنيه الذين حددتهم
السلطات بانهم من وحدات حمايه الشعب الامر
الذي قد يعيد الحديث مره اخرى عن عمليه
عسكريه مرتقبه في سوريا اسطنبول
وزاره العدل الاسرائيليه باحتمال طلب مواد
للتحقيق في وفاه الزميله شيرين
اسطنبول معنا من اسطنبول
الامني والاستراد سيدي يوسف مع مرور
الساعات وتتالي هذه البيانات من وزاره
الداخليه التركيه ما الذي تكشف عن حيثيات
والهدف من التفجير يطلع اسطنبول في اليوم
الماضي
من وزاره الداخليه التركيه
اعلنت ان
الارهابيه التي نفذت هذا الهجوم
اذا كانت
قد عملت
حمايه الشعب الكرديه وحزب العمال
الكردستاني الهدف هو ارسال رساله الى
تركيا التي تواجه
الارهاب في العراق وفي سوريا وهذه الحرب
على الارهاب
هي في الداخل وفي الخارج وايضا هناك رساله
لاجزاء اخرى من العالم بان هذه المنظمات
لا تزال قويه الان الكل ينتظر طبيعته الرد
والتعامل التركي مع هذا التفجير
التركي
ان تركيا تواجه منظمات ارهابيه منذ
اربعه عقود تقريبا وبالتالي نتحدث عن
منظمه ارهابيه ولديها اهداف ولكن تركيا
يختلف بنسبه اليها الوضع لاننا نتحدث عن
دوله وبالتالي هناك سلسله من القرارات
التي يجب ان تتخذ على مستوى رسمي اعتقدوا
من وجهه نظري ان تركيا سوف تستمر بالرد في
الميداني السوري اذا ما عدنا الى تصريحات
وزير الداخليه
قال ان
الدوافع تعود الى وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه في الداخل السوري وبالتالي
السلطات التركيه يمكنها ان تركز على
مجموعات وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه داخل
السوريه قامت تركيا باجراء عمليات في
الداخل السوري ولا ربما نشهد عمليات
اضافيه بعض هذا الهجوم الذي استهدف ميدان
تقسم الجهه التي نفذت هذا التفجير يبدو
انها كانت تريد احداث اكبر
صدى اعلام من خلال اختيار هذا الشارع
بالاضافه الى كونه في اسطنبول
هل حققت هذا الهدف
على الارجح نعم لانه عندما نعاين كل
الانشطه الارهابيه
المنظمات
الارهابيه لا تسعى الى
تدمير الدوله او تفكيك الدوله او تركيا
الدوله
والاستراتيجي شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
اذن بالعوده للخبر العاجل وردته اكسيوس
موقع اكسيوس عن مصادر ان وزاره العدل
الامريكيه ابلغت نظرتها الاسرائيليه بفتح
مكتب التحقيق الفيدرالي تحقيقا في مقتل
الزميله شيرين ابو عاقله وقد نقلت صحيفتها
ارتست عن ان 57 وشرعا امريكيا بعثوا رساله
لمدير الشرطه الفيدراليه الامريكيه اف بي
اي ووزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطونيو
بلانكن يطالبون بتحقيق في قتل شيرين ابو
عاقله واكدت الرساله انها شيرين ابو عاقله
كمواطن امريكيه لها الحق في الحمايه
الكامله التي توفر للامريكيين الذين
يعيشون في الخارج وكان المتحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القوميه الامريكيه قال ان شيرين لم
تكن مواطنه امريكيه بحسب بل مراسله شجاعه
نالت احترام الجميع واضاف ان الولايات
المتحده لن تعلق على مواضيع تخص انفاذ
القانون وقلوبنا مع عائله ابو عاقله حسب
ما جاء في تعبيره وفي اخبار عاجله كمان
نتبعها على الشاشه كما قلنا نقلا عن موقع
اكسيوس التحقيق الامريكي بشان مقتل شاب
عقل يقول امر غير اعتيادي ويمكن ان يشمل
الجنود الذين شاركوا في هذه
العمليه
وكذلك موقع ولا لساني مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي
الامريكي فتح تحقيقا جنائيا بظروف مقتل
الصحفيه شيرين ابو عاقله وايضا عن ذات
الموقع وزاره العدل الامريكي
الاسرائيليه بفتح مكتب الاف بي اي تحقيقا
بمقتل الزميله شيرين
وننوه ايضا لهذا الخبر العاجل ايضا عن
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي بان
الامريكيين ابلغ وزاره العدل ال ال
اسرائيليه بانه تم فتح تحقيق في واشنطن في
بشان مقتل الزميله شيرين ابو عاقله اذا عن
هذه الاخبار المتتاليه معنا من واشنطن
مراسل مراسلت الجزيره بيسان ابو كويك ومن
القدس الياس كرم وابدا معك بيسان بهذه
الاخبار
العاجله ما نقله موقع اكسيوس عن همم هذا
التوجه الامريكي الى فتح تحقيق وابلاغ
الجانب الاسرائيلي بذلك
نعم حتى هذه اللحظه ما لدينا هو ما نقله
موقع اكسيوس عبد القادر بانه تم ابلاغ
الجانب الاسرائيلي بهذه النيه لفتح هذا
التحقيق وان هذا التحقيق وفق مقالته
اكسيوس امر غير اعتيادي وانه سيسفر عن طلب
تحقيقات مع الاشخاص المعنيين ومنهم جنود
اسرائيليين طبعا لا نعلم الرد الاسرائيلي
حتى الان نحن بدورنا ايضا نتواصل مع
الجهات المعنيه هنا للتاكد مما اوردته
يعني من وزاره العدل الامريكيه بالنسبه
لمتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
كان قد قال لي الجزيره ان همم الجهات
المعنيه هي جهات انفاذ القانون لتاكيد هذا
الخبر ولكنه تحدث عن شيرين في تعليقه
للجزيره بانها طبعا لم تكن حلقات مواطنه
امريكيه ولكن كانت صحفيه شجاع
وتنال الاحترام حول العالم ولكن عبد
القادر كما تعلم ايضا ان هذه الخطوه همم
هي تاتي حين طبعا نتاكد منها ايضا من
مصادرنا نحن هنا تاتي بعض ضغوط متواصله من
اعضاء الكونجرس على مدار اشهر لفتح تحقيق
مستقل
وشفاف ودي مصداقيه في ظروف مقتل الزميله
شيرين ابو عاقله رسائل متتاليه وجهت من
قبل اعضاء في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي واعضاء
في مجلس النواب الامريكي للوزير وايضا
للرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن له فتح هذا
التحقيق وايضا طبعا لا الاف بي اي نظرا
لان المراجعه التي تمت من قبل المنقصق
الامني حين تمت قبل عده اشهر البعض هنا
رحب بها ولك ومعتبروها غير كافيه ولا تجيب
عن الكثير من الاسئله وكان هناك حتى بيان
شديد اللهجه من السيناتور الديمقراطي
باتريك ليه قبل نحو شهر يعني قال ان هذه
التحقيقات ضروري جدا وانه امر اعتيادي وفق
قوله ان يفتح تحقيق حين يستهدف مواطن
امريكي وصحفي بهذا الشكل
اذهب الى الياس كرم ما نقله نقله اذاعه
الجيش الاسرائيلي بان واشنطن ابلغت وزاره
العدل الاسرائيليه باحتمال طلب مواد
للتحقيق في وفاه شيرين
الياس نحن امام خطوه الان اصبحت مؤكده
هي خطوه متطوره جدا ومتقدمه في سياق هذا
التحقيق في هذه الجريمه التي اودت بحياه
الزميله الراحله شيرين ابو عاقله لكن من
الواضح بان اسرائيل الرسمي حتى هذه الساعه
تلتزم الصمت حيال هذه الانباء التي اصبحت
ربما شبه مؤكده على اعتبار ان وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه وزنه قد تلقفتها على
قدر كبير ووضعتها على صدر صفحاتها الاولى
وفي عناوينها الرئيسيه في المواقع نشير
هنا الى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ اللحظه
الاولى من جريمه اغتيال الزميله الراحله
شيرين ابو عقلي قد رفض جمله وتفصيلا فتحه
تحقيق جنائي مع الجنود الذين
تورطوا في هذه الجريمه
والجيش الاسرائيلي قال بانه لن يفتح اي
تحقيق جنائي في هذه الحادثه كما سماها على
اعتبار انه يرسل جنوده الى الميدان
لمحاربه الارهاب وان الزميله شيرين ابو
عاقل وكانه يريد ان يتهم قد تواجدت في
معركه في في ميدان قتال ما بين جنود الجيش
الاسرائيلي وبين مسلحين فلسطينيين كانوا
يطلقون النار بشكل عشوائي وعندما قال
الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه لا يريد ان يفتح
تحقيقا جنائيا هو كان يقصد بانه لن يفتح
تحقيقا ولن يكون هنالك تقديم ايضا الجنود
او الضباط الذين تواجدوا في مسرح الجريمه
للتحقيق في الشرطه العسكريه الاسرائيليه
ومن ثم فتح ملف جنائي في النيابه العسكريه
ضدهم على اعتبار ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يرى
بان هذه خطوه غير اخلاقيه نشير هنا ايضا
الى ان التحقيقات التي اجراها الجيش
الاسرائيلي كانت تحقيقات داخليه عسكريه
ميدانيه عملتيه فقط ولم تتطرق الى اي جانب
من الجوانب الجنائيه لهذه الجريمه همم
سوى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي حقق في همم ظروف
ما جرى هناك ولم
اسماء الجنود او الضباط المتورطين ولا
اسماء ربما الوحده التي كانت موجوده وعملت
في مخيم جنين في ذلك اليوم رغم ان الوحده
معروفه للجميع وهي وحده دوف ديفان كما ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي رفض اعطاء اي معلومات
حول شخصيه الجنود او نشر اي صور او
معلومات
الجانب الاسرائيلي مع هذا الطالب الامريكي
في بحال ما اذا تعلق الامر بالتحقيق مع
جنود اسرائيليين
وهذا بالطبع ما سيؤدي الى صدام كبير ما
بين واشنطن وتل ابيب في هذه النقطه تحديدا
وهذا ايضا ربما مكان للتساؤل عن التوقيت
في هذا الاعلان الاعلان عن فتح التحقيق
الجنائي من جانب ال مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي هل هنالك علاقه ربما مع
الانقلاب السياسي الذي حدث هنا في اسرائيل
صعود اليمين المتطرف اا ربما هل لهذا
علاقه هذا السؤال يجب ان يطرح وبقوه في
هذا التوقيت لكن من الواضح بان قناه
الجزيره وعائله الراحله شيرين ابو عاقله
والمؤسسات الحقوقيه والصحفيه حول العالم
كانت تشكل ضغطا كبيرا على الاداره
الامريكيه في الشهور الاخيره من اجل فتحي
تحقيق من هذا النوع على اعتبار ان هذا
التحقيق ربما يحقق شيئا من العداله
الغائبه للزميل الراحله شيرين ابو عاقله
على اعتبار ان كل التحقيقات التي اجريت
سواء التحقيق الامريكي الذي ايه اجره همم
همم المنسق الامريكي مايك بنزل الذي اشار
رغم انه اجرى تحقيقا بالسيا وحقق في
الرصاصه ايضا التي همم قتلت الزميل
الراحله شيرين ابو عقلي وافضل تقريره في
نهايه المطاف الى انه لا يمكن الجزم
والتحديد بشكل قاطع على ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي هو من قتل الزميل ابو عقل وهذا
ما اثار حفيظه عائله شيرين وايضا قناه
الجزيره وكذلك الكثيرين من المراقبين
والمتابعين لهذه القضيه التي اصبحت قضيه
عالميه وليست فقط قضيه خاصه همم كل
التحقيقات الصحفيه وكذلك المدعي العام
الفلسطيني ااه اشار بشكل واضح الى انك انه
كان هنالك يتعمد من جانب جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي على اصابه الزميل الراحله
شيرين ابو عاقله التي كانت تلبس البزه همم
صحفيه الستره الواقيه والخوذه وكانت مع
مجموعه من الصحفيين
كل هذه التحقيقات كانت فندت في السابق همم
كل مزاعم الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي غير
روايتنا واكثر من مره في الايام الاولى في
محاوله للتستر عن هذه الجريمه على ان
هنالك كان قتالا او اشتباك مسلحا بين
مقاتلين فلسطينيين وجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وهذا ما نفته كل التحقيقات
المحليه والدوليه جمله وتفصيلا واكدت بان
الرصاصه اطلقت من جانب الجيش الاسرائيلي
عمدا باتجاه الصحفيين وباتجاه الزميله
الراحله شيرين ابو عقل ارجو ان تبقى معي
الياس كذلك ليس لاستقبل رمضان الدكتور
مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام المبادره
الوطنيه الفلسطيني دكتور مصطفى الزميل
الياس قبل الاشاره الى مساله التوقيت لهذه
الخطوه الامريكيه
هل لديك من تفسير
متاخرا جدا
العامل الاول
وهو يجب ان يقدر الجهد الهائل الذي ابتل
من قبل عائله
راحله زميله شيرين ابو
اسره الجزيره وكل مؤسسات حقوق الانسان
والمؤسسات الصحفيه الدوليه لان ذلك خلق
ضغط كبيرا بما في ذلك على اعضاء الكونغرس
ومجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
العامل الثاني ان التحقيقات الاسرائيليه
كانت فضيحه بالمعنى الكامل للكلمه لانها
حاولت ان تتستر بشكل كامل على الجريمه
الذي وقعت وحاولت ان تغطي على هذه الجريمه
واضيف الى ذلك ايضا موقف كان يمثل فضيحه
لوزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه التي حاولت ان
تقول ان قتل الش- زميل شيرين ابو عقله لم
يكن متعمدا وكان ذلك خطا اخر وقعت في هذه
الاداره الان في عامل ثالث بدون شك اعتقد
انه مهم وهو ما اشير اليه قبل قليل من قبل
مراسلكوم وهو ان التغير في اسرائيل ربما
الان فتح الابواب ايه
تحقيق الجديد لانه فعلا في احتكاك الان
بين
العنصريين المتطرفين الذين جاءوا للحكم
اسرائيل ومع هذه الاداره فربما الاداره
رفعت
يدها وبالتالي فتح المجال الان لاجراء
تحقيق ينصف ربما قليلا ويحقق بعض
العادات لما جرى لشيرين ابو عقل ولكن
علينا ان ننتظر وانا اعتقد ان
شعبيه ودوليا ورسميا يجب ان يستمر بقوه
كبيره
مع هذه الخطوات الامريكيه
بالغه التطرف والاجرام ولكن اعتقد ان يشكل
ضغطا ايضا وهذا ضغط مفيد ومهم كلما اليوم
انا براي لدينا فرصه ذهبيه لفضح وتعريه
حكومه اسرائيل لان حكومات كثيره كانت
متطرفه موجوده في السابق ولكن هذه الحكومه
اكثر انكشافا وهناك فرصه كبيره جدا وذهبيه
في الواقع لتصنيف احزاب في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه مثل حزب البندقيه على انه
حركه ارهابيه وبالتالي يجب استثمار هذه
الفرصه الى النهايه والان فتح التحقيق في
موضوع الزميله شيرين ابو عقله يشكل ثغره
وفجاه يجب ان نستخدمها بكل قوه لتحقيق
العداله ليس فقط للشريرين بل 52 صحه في
فلسطين الذين قتلهم الجيش الاحتلال من عام
2000 وللشعب الفلسطيني الذي يعاني الامرين
من القمع والقتل الاسرائيلي الذي راينا
مظهرا له في قتل فتاه في فلسطين لماذا
وصفت الخطه الامريكيه بانها متاخره وهل
لهذا التاخير تاثير على همم مسار هذه
القضيه ومعرفه الحقيقه
انا قلت متاخره لانه للاسف الموقف
الامريكي الاول الذي صدر كان يقول رغم انه
وجود تاكيدات بان شيرين قد قتلت بيد الجيش
الاسرائيلي الا ان هذا القتل لم يكن
متعمدا وكل الدلائل اشارت الى ان القتل
كان متعمدا بما في ذلك الوقائع الميدانيه
بما في ذلك همم ال 10 رصاصات التي اصابت
الشجره التي كانت تقف بجانب عشرين ابو
عاقله بالتالي بالتفسيرات الامريكيه كانت
خاطئه ولم يجري فتح التحقيق فورا لذلك انا
اقول انها متاخره ولكن هذا لن يؤثر في
نتيجه التحقيق ومن رايي بالعكس لانه في
شعور بالذنب ربما هنا وفي شعور بالتقصير
ربما هذا يساعد على ان يكون التحقيق افضل
لكن علينا ان مواصل للظهر وعلينا ان نطول
نواصل المطالبه بالحقيقه وانه مش بس ان
يحدد من قاموا بالقتل من اعطاهم الاوامر
وفي اي ظروف جامعه المساله و لماذا تستمر
عمليات القتل ضد الفلسطينيين الانبياء
بلغ عدد الفلسطينيين الذين استشهدوا بدايه
هذا العام 199 فلسطين فلسطيني منهم 44 طفل
رقم
قتل هذا ما يجب التركيز عليه مش جريمه
اغتيال شيرين ابو عقله هي مظهر لعمليه
متواصله وجاريه من قبل نظام فاشي نظام
عنصري نظام اجرامي ضد الشعب الفلسطيني
شكرا لكم تبعنا من رام الله دكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي الامين العام المبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطيني
هل نحن امام مسار قانوني جدي الان بما
اتخذت وزاره العدل الامريكيه والتسليم
الملف لمكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
بي سي
طبعا نحن نتحدث وبكل تاكيد عن تطور مهم
انا وزاره العدل يبدو انها ابلغت وزاره
العدل الاسرائيليه بانه تم فتح تحقيق بهذه
القضيه هناك طبعا ولايه قضائيه وفقا
للقانون الامريكي لكي يتم هذا التحقيق
ولكي يكون هناك احتمال محاكمه في المستقبل
انتظرت للقيام بذلك بعد الانتخابات
التشديد
تصفيق لا يؤثر ذلك على
الدعم الذي يخضع به الحسبه الديمقراطيطي
وقد يؤدي ذلك الى محاكمه جنائيه
للاشخاص الذين ها نفذ او اطلقوا النار اذا
ما فتحت تحقيق على مستوى المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه على الارجح سوف يركز يركز ذاك
التحقيق على السياسات ومن وضع سياسات ومن
هي الجهه المسؤوله على مستوى حكوميه اعلى
همم عن مقتل شيرين ابو عاقله ولكن وزاره
العدل الامريكيه تركز في تحقيقها على
الشخص الذي قتلها طيب نستغل خبرتك
القانونيه سيد همم بما نقاله موقع اكسيوس
بان الجانب الامريكي قد يطلب بعض مواد
التحقيق من الجانب الاسرائيلي ما المقصود
بمواد التحقيق
ايوه ماشي
ان تطلب من وزاره العدل الاسرائيليه
معلومات
وكان هناك بعض
المعلومات التي تم تشاركها في السابق
ويتحدث هنا عن الرصاصه على الطلقه التي
عرضت على المسؤولين الامريكيين في اسرائيل
وذكر ادى الى
تصريحا غريب من قبل مسؤول ان رفيع في
الوفد الامريكي تحدث عن ضرر في ال- همم
تلقى ولم يتم تحديث الجهه التي اطلقت
النار ولكن في نفس الوقت تحدث عن عمليه
اطلاق النار لم تكن متعمدا كان هذا
الاستنتاج غريبا وغير منطقي ولكن الان
يبدو ان وزاره العدل تاخذ القضيه على محبل
الجد طيب كان هناك لقاء امني همم سابق
ثلاثي امريكي اسرائيلي فلسطيني وتم فيه
استعراض
مستند الجريمه وهو ال- ال- الرصاصه
وبالتالي ما الذي قد يضاف كمواد للتحقيق
هل يمكن ان تشمل همم بعض الجنود
ان تكون وزاره العدل مهتمه
بهويه الشخص الذي اطلقه الرصاصه وهذه
المعلومه لم تفصح عنها السلطات
الاسرائيليه انه وزاره العدل قد تطلب على
سبيل المثال مقابله الشخص الذي اطلق
الرصاصه وهنا يطرح السؤال المهم على
الحكومه الاسرائيليه هل سوف تسمح لوزاره
العدل الامريكيه تقوم بذلك ولكن بكل وضوح
هذا من ضمن الولايات القضائيه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه بالنظري الى
ان شيرين ابو عاقله هي مواطنه امريكيه
ووفقا للتدابير والاجراءات القضاء هي
والقانونيه الدوليه
يتعين على السلطات الاسرائيليه ان تتعاون
مع هكذا تحقيقه ماذا اذا لم يتجاوب الجانب
الاسرائيلي مع هذه الدعوه الامريكيه
الصعوبه بالنسبه الى اسرائيل ان لا تقدم
اي معلومات بهذا الخصوص
اذا ما قررت الحكومه الاسرائيليه ان تمتنع
عن تقديم اي معلومات لا يمكن والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ان تقوم بالكثير بهذا
الخصوص ان وزاره العدل في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يمكنها ان تمضي قدما في
تحقيقها من دون الحصول على معلومات اضافيه
من اسرائيل ووزاره العدل قد تتمكن من
تقديم ادله
بشان هويه مطلق النار وبالتالي وزاره
العدل قد تتمكن من المضيق قدما من دون
الحصول على معلومات اضافيه من الحكومه
الاسرائيليه هناك كميه كبيره من المعلومات
المتاحه وهناك معلومات نشرت على شبكه
الانترنت
بناء على صور الاقمار الاصطناعيه
ما جمع هذه الصور من قبل منظمات مختلفه
وبالتالي حتى ولو قررت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه اللا تتعاون قد يكون بحوزه
وزاره العدل ما يكفي من معلومات لكي تقوم
حتى باذنه هويه المنفذ
شكرا جزيلا لك واعود الى بيسان كان هناك
جديد ما يتعلق بهذه الخطوه الامريكيه وكان
قبل قليل الزميل الياس اثار مساله التوقيع
ان كانت هناك مؤشرات تفسر توقيت هذه
الخطوه من قبل وزاره العدل الامريكيه الان
عبد القادر في اول ربما تعليق من وزاره
العدل الامريكيه على استفسار قمنا بارساله
من مكتبنا هنا رفضت وزاره العدل الامريكيه
التعليق على هذا الاستفسار ولكن هناك ايضا
اول رد فعل يصدر من الكونجرس من السانوتر
الديمقراطيسي الذي كان قد تزعم وقاد جهود
عده رسائل خلال الاشهر الماضيه وجهت الى
وزير الخارجيه والى مدير مكتبه تحقيقات
الفيدرا لكريسري لفتح تحقيق مستقل في مقتل
الزميله شيرين ابو عاقله
معلقا على ان الاف بي اي فتح هذا التحقيق
يقول ان هذه خطوه طال انتظارها لكنها
ضروريه وهمه في مسعى لتحقيق العداله
والمحاسبه في مقتل شيرين ابو عاقله لذا
اول رد فعل ربما ياتي من الكونجرس رغم رفض
الاداره الامريكيه متمثله بوزاره العدل
الامريكيه تاكيد او التعليق على اا قضيه
فتح التحقيق ولكن بالنسبه للتوقيت هناك
ربما كما يعني ذكر الضيوف والزميل الياس
كالرام ربما هناك عده مؤشرات داله على
موضوع التوقيت اولا انتهاء الانتخابات
النصفيه هذه ربما دلاله هامه ان الحملات
الانتخابيه انتهت الان نبدا مرحله جديده
خصوصا مع ما حققته الاداره يعني حققه
الديمقراطيون على الاقل حتى الان من
الحفاظ على سيطرتهم على مجلس الشيوخ
القضيه الاخرى هي طبعا اداره
تعول ربما على فوز همم يائيل لابيد رئاسه
الوزراء الان هذا قمر اخر او او الصوره
والواقع مختلف تماما في اسرائيل مع فوز
بنيامين نتنياهو ربما قد يكون لهذا الامر
ايضا همم وقع بسبب هذا التوقيت طبعا لن
تسمع من الاداره الامريكيه او مسؤولين
امريكيين او حتى اعضاء في الكونغرس
يتحدثون عن قضيه التوقيت او لن ينظر
تصريحات تصب في هذا الاتجاه ولكن في
التحليلات قد يكون لهذين الحدثين دلالات
على هذا الامر خصوصا ان الضغوط لم تتوقف
على هذه الاداره منذ اللحظه الاولى
الاختيار لزميله شيرين ابو عاقله لان كان
في الكونجرس وطبعا الزياره التي قامت بها
عائله شيرين وضغوطها على هذه الاداره همم
عائله شيرين ابو عاقله وشقيقها وابنه
اخيها كان هنا في الصيف التقوا اعضاء في
الكونجرس هناك يعني تواصل وما مع بعض
المكاتب تصب في هذا الاتجاه في هذه الضغوط
لقائهم في وزير الخارجيه انتن بلانكن
لذا كل هذا اخذ وقتا من الاداره الامريكيه
كي تتحرك لفتح هذا التحقيق ولكن في ردود
الفعل الاولى سيلقى ترحيبا خصوصا في
الكونجرس الامريكي 57 عضو في مجلس النواب
و 24 عضو في مجلس الشيوخ كانوا قد بعثوا
برسائل ولم يكونوا ربما راضين عن الردود
الفعل الاوليه التي صدرت عن الاداره
الامريكيه يعني حين صدر التصريح من
الخارجيه الامريكيه فيما يتعلق
المتابعته هذا المستجد ولكن مع الزبيلين
وسيله وجلال ونشرت منتصف الليل